so you kind of talk about reason
where does uh the kind of existentialist
idea of
experience maybe you know fully
experiencing all the moments
versus fully thinking through
is there interesting lines to separate
the two like
why such an emphasis on reason for life
well lived
versus just enjoy like
experience well because i think
experience in a sense is the
easy part yeah i'm not saying it's it's
it's how we experience the life that we
live and yes i'm
all with the take time to to to
value what you value but i think i don't
think that's the problem of people out
there i don't think the problem is
they're not taking time to appreciate
where they are and what they do
i think it's that they don't use their
mind in this
one respect in planning their life
and thinking about how to live so the
focus is on reason is because
it's our only source of knowledge
there's no other source of knowledge we
don't
know anything with it you know that does
not come
from our senses in our in our mind the
integration of the of the evidence of
our senses
now we know stuff about ourselves and i
think it's important to know oneself
through introspection
and i can't consider that part of
reasoning is to
is to introspect but i think reason is
undervalued
which is funny to say because it's our
means of survival it's how human beings
survive
we cannot see this is why i disagree
with so many
scientists and and people like sam
harris you mentioned the same house
before the show
um we're not programmed
to know how to hunt we're not programmed
to do agriculture we're not programmed
to
build computers and build networks on
which we can podcast and do our shows
all of that requires effort it requires
focus it requires energy and it requires
will it requires somebody to will it
it requires somebody to choose it and
once you make that
choice you have to engage that choice
means that you're choosing to engage
your reason
in discovery in integration
and then in work to change the world in
which we live
and you know human beings have to
discover
figure out solve the problem of hunting
hunting
you know everybody thinks oh that's easy
i've seen the movie but
human beings had to figure out how to do
it right you you you can't
run down a bison and bite into it right
you're not gonna catch it you're not
gonna you have no
fangs to bite into it you have to build
weapons you have to build tools you have
to create traps you have to have a
strategy
all of that requires reason so
the most important thing that allows
human beings to survive and to thrive in
every value from the most simple to the
most sophisticated
for the most material to i believe the
most spiritual
requires thinking so
stopping and appreciating the moment is
is something that i think is relatively
easy
once you have a plan once you've thought
it through once you know what your
values are
there is a mistake people make they
attain their values and they just and
they just they don't
take a moment to savor that and to
appreciate that and to even pat
themselves on the back that they did it
right
but that's not what's screwing up the
world what's screwing up the world is
that people have the wrong values and
they don't think about them and they
don't really focus on them and they
don't have a plan
for their own life and how to live it if
we look at human nature
you're saying the fundamental big thing
that we need to consider
is our capacity like a capability to
reason
so to me reason is this massive
evolutionary achievement right in quotes
right
um if you think about any other
sophisticated animal
everything has to be coded everything
has to be written
in in the hard way it has to be there
yeah and
they have to have a solution for the
outcome and if there's no solution
animal dies typically or the animal
suffers in some way
human beings have this capacity to
self-program they have this capacity
it there's not it's not a uh uh
tabla rasa in the sense that there's
nothing there obviously we have a nature
obviously our minds our brains are
structured in a particular way
but given that we have the ability to
turn it on or turn it off
we have the ability to commit suicide to
to reject our nature to work against our
interests
not to use the tool that evolution has
provided us with
which is this mind which is reason so
that
choice that fundamental choice you know
uh hamlet says it right to be or not to
be but to be or not to be is
to think on how to think to engage or
not to engage to focus or not to focus
you know in the morning when you get up
you kind of you know
you're not you're not really completely
there you're kind of out of focus and
stuff
it requires an act of will to say okay
i'm awake i've got stuff to do
some people never do that some people
live in that haze
and they never engage that mind and when
you when you're sitting and trying to
solve
a complex computer program problem or
math problem
you have to turn something on you have
to
in a sense it exerts certain energy
to focus on the problem to do it and
that is not
determined in a sense that you have to
focus
you choose to focus and you could choose
not to focus
you